kim kardashian says no therapy can fix
her marriage with kanye west
in court documents obtained by e.t on
monday the 41 year old reality star
states that her relationship with the
grammy winner is beyond repair this on
the heels from last week when the kkw
beauty founder filed to be declared
legally single and to drop west from her
last name the latest docs further
emphasize her desire to quote terminate
their marital status at the end of the
day life is about being happy the court
date for their divorce hearing is set
for march 22nd but kim is requesting
that the issues regarding custody of the
couple's four children as well as
property matters and a division of
assets be dealt separately from the
issue of their marital status allowing
kim to be legally single sooner the
documents add quote the party's marriage
has irremediably broken down kim
kardashian no longer desires to be
married to kanye west there is no
question that the marriage of the
parties is no longer viable and despite
kanye's efforts to win back his
estranged wife the docs state that kim
has quote no desire to reconcile quote
irreconcilable differences have led to
the irremediable breakdown of the
marriage and there is no possibility of
saving the marriage through counseling
or other means in her declaration kim
notes that she has been attempting to
settle the dissolution with kanye since
she first filed for divorce in february
adding that she has requested that he
agreed to terminate their marital status
but he has not responded to her request
kim concluded that both she and kanye
deserve the opportunity to build new
lives
last week the 44 year old rapper begged
his ex to literally run back to him at
his la concert updating the lyrics to
his hit song run away
and last month yay appeared on the
podcast drink champs and opened up about
his impending divorce
my kids want their parents to stay
together i want they pair i want us to
be together but if you like to be
together too if you look at the media
that's not what they promoting
that's not what they want they want it
to be a new wedding a new episode a new
tv show and then they have people all
around and my wife here kim filed for
divorce after six years of marriage and
has asked for joint legal and physical
custody of their children north saint
chicago and psalm a source told et at
the time that the rapper was fine with
the joint custody agreement and the two
were committed to co-parenting together
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through the
source also noted that neither kim nor
kanye planned to contest their prenup
and at the time they were in the process
of reaching a property settlement
agreement and while kim has been
supportive of kanye attending his shows
and co-parenting she is currently dating
saturday night live star pete davidson
the two have been spotted out on several
dates since sparking romance rumors back
in october following kim's hosting gig
on snl i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not i sure
am jasmine
[Music]
but a source tells e.t kim has been
protective of kanye and his feelings and
has been trying to keep her hangouts
with pete low key i always believe and
trust in him that he will
always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart as for her
budding romance a source told et this
week quote kim is giddy when pete's
around kim feels relaxed and comfortable
with pete and she definitely has that
new crush feeling with him